[Music]
Hank that's your standing ovation for
the Helen Hunt song good morning Hank
it's Thursday April 26 the Pacific Ocean
is behind me in Los Angeles is in front
of me Hank it's been a day of crazy
Hollywood meetings and so I thought I'd
give you a quick run-through of
everything that's happened first my
agent and I were walking down the beach
in Los Angeles when he came across this
sculpture and I was like what is that a
sculpture of sure looks like a sculpture
of something dirty and then I walked
around it and uh it's the Virgin Mary
weird mission for the nerdfighters find
this guy statistical chances I don't
like that guy
100% Hank this is the most important
meeting I have today to people who might
want to turn an abundance of katherines
into a movie in retrospect I probably
shouldn't have eaten the whole barbecue
chicken pita about 12 minutes ago over
the course of about 48 seconds thank you
remember when you were in like eighth
grade and occurred to you for the first
time that there were people who might
actually like you and be willing to be
your friend and how exciting that was it
seems to me that everyone in Los Angeles
is stuck in eighth grade they're still
so excited about the chance that
somebody somewhere might like them oh my
god I like you so much I like you too
you're bright I love you you look great
in that also Hank everywhere you go
there are speakers like this pointing
outside playing music like that
okay Hank it's time for the meeting here
we are outside the building I'm going to
show you what it looks like real quick
they're very very welcoming check it out
here it's like the opposite of Los
Angeles
I mean you have to say a per square inch
it contains more items than any other
place I've ever been inside of I'm
reminded a little bit of my college
girlfriend rape on Zillow whose parents
had the largest Santa Claus collection
on the East Coast you know what I keep
thinking mom would be so happy here I
mean - mom this would be like Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory she
would just be so happy Hank I have great
news I can see into the future here's my
question for madam Seymour is it ever
going to happen between Hank and Helen
Hunt um would I do a good job writing
the abundance of Katherine's screen but
you just told me no so anyway Hank the
meeting ended up going really well madam
Seymour be damned see you tomorrow PS
any nerdfighters want to participate in
top secret project email me at John it's
Park Slope calm